hello everyone and welcome to game 14 of
the 1960 World Chess Championship match
between Michael tal and Mikhail
Botvinnik now as you've seen in game 13
the game ended after only 50 15 minutes
it was a 16 move draw Kyle talked about
how he was very tired how about when he
was very tired and after that game tile
got sick and the game the game 14 wasn't
played for another five days so of 14th
of April was game number number 13 and
the 19th of April was game number 14 so
five days of rest for tal he got better
but during those five days he and
Koblenz definitely had more time to
decide how to counter both winning with
the white pieces so they acquired a book
by mark time' know about the names of
indian defense and also they acquired
botany book Botvinnik wrote about his
return match against miss love and the
in that book botanic says how he didn't
really win that match by playing better
chess but rather by by you know
improving his own psychology and this
this is something that really interested
tall and Coblentz and they of course
studied it so using time on of the book
they found they found a nice variation
of the names of indian defense which
they thought that botany couldn't really
be familiar with as they improved the
variation a bit but okay let's see the
game Botvinnik opens with d4 so this is
the second half of the match botany it
doesn't really have the luxury of going
for some slower openings he he has to go
for a fight he's still down two points
in the match and if he continues to draw
games taller will simply win the
championship
so knight to f6 c4 e6 and Knight to c3
botnik doesn't mind going for the
nimzo-indian so Bishop to b4 tall
doesn't mind either so the nimzo-indian
defense
a3 Bishop captures on c3b captures on c3
and this was a toss idea in this match
Knight to e4 immediately and it's it's
it's a very complicated variation you do
have to consider a lot of things and a
lot of lines were written by many
players in in in
book where towel prepared at a time
enough suggest Queen to c2 and after
Queen to c2 the following variation
Knight to e4
this is this comes the night comes to e4
with the idea of immediately pushing f5
so this is of course good for black III
b6 now you've cemented that knight on e4
now you're gonna play Bishop to b7
assume this beautiful diagonal and it's
gonna be very hard to kick this night
away from me for Bishop to d3 now Bishop
to b7 defending the knight knife to e2
now Queen to h4 castles castles and
after f3 Knight to g5 so this was a time
on of the recommendation in his book and
he considers that this offers equal
chances today it's considered that white
is white is better here but in those
days it was considered perfectly fine
but after night before botanique doesn't
go for time on of recommendation and
this is one of the reasons I chose this
quote above the board where tall often
spoke of Botvinnik
as the master of opening preparation
here botany plays nice to h3 and the
Knight to h3 was a was a known variation
but he didn't expect he didn't expect
the botnik to play it as a Knight to h3
is considered a lesser moved and Queen
to c2
but then again talha tal was ready for
Queen to c2 but he wasn't ready for
Knight to h3 so here c5 was played there
is no need to push f5 now since your
night wasn't attacked by Queen to c2 of
course you can't capture this pawn if
you capture then Queen to c2 and you
don't have a retreat Square for your
knight you'll lose a piece here so after
Knight to h3 calvo's c5 we have III and
Queen to a5 threatening to grab that c3
pawn we have Bishop to d2 both winning
defends it and here top plays C captures
on d4 tal wasn't very impressed by this
move himself as he says seek after sandy
4 is basically a draw for you don't
really have a lot of complications here
you know I love you do allow white to
play e captures on d4 which would
definitely indicate that botanique is
interested in a fight but it's it's
considered to be a less removed in C
capture Sunday for which botanique
played but this is basically botany
accepting a draw so knife capture Sunday
- Oh Queen capture screen captures and
the King capture Sun b2 b6 Bishop to d3
and now Bishop to a6 here
there still might be some poison to the
position top plays Bishop to a6
attacking the c4 pawn and he's preparing
to go Knight to c6 Knight to a5 so the
knight can attack the c4 pawn and to
bring this rook to c8 further pressure
to c4 pawn we have rook H to c1 and rook
H to see one is the correct idea by
botany Bishop to g4 with the idea of
moving the bishop and protecting you
later because this comes with a temple
on the rook Knight to c6 and now d5e
capture C captures and after Knight to
a5 it's actually white that would be in
danger here because this night would get
a lot of squares to harass the King
so after Bishop to h6 rook age to c1 a
correct idea
tonight the c6 preparing Knight to a5
rook a to be 1 and King to e7 here talk
on it connects his rooks and prepares to
bring the a truck into the game about
the botanique doesn't fall out how to
organize any kind of an attack against
the C pawn he pushes c5 himself and
offers a series of exchanges so Bishop
captures on d3 Kim captures on d3 and
now rook a to b8 rope to b5 in hopes of
maybe later pushing d5 and and ruining
talus bone structure but tall doesn't
mind exchanging pieces here so B
captures on c5 rook captures on c5 and
now a 6 as now the B file is the
important file so rook captures rook
captures tal wins the B file and here
botany is forced to play King to c2 so
the King has to go back the King has the
guard b1 and b2 so the rook cannot
infiltrate the position and here top
plate rook to c8 so the B file is no
longer of any use he transfers the roof
to the C file and as he played rook to
c8 he offer Botvinnik a draw but in this
position botany actually declined the
draw he played nice too
for considering his position was better
d6 attacking the rook but when he moves
the rook rook to c3 and here top plays
g5 and at this moment when top way g5
botanique then considered a draw again
AB now both eunuch offered a draw and
this time tau agreed to a draw because
as tal says that this position could not
be any more drawn what Paul gives after
g5 something like Knight 2 D 3 can be
played and after king to d7 a knight to
the before and after you change
everything
it's King to c6 and it's a completely
drawn endgame so after this g5 move by
tau after this g5 move by tau botnik
offered the draw and they agreed to a
draw so there we have it this was game
number 14 again I draw and again thought
keeps his 2-point lead in the match and
botanique will definitely have to start
doing something about this either play
sharper lines or something but if he
continues drawing games then Todd will
definitely win the championship so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Joseph bisetti and
Steven bird for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate that as usual you can check
to my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
probably would a game from the rank each
as classic thank you